foreign
[Music]
welcome back to our next episode of the
series called language shapes perception
today we're talking about one of the
most requested topics among teenagers
today with you is Professor s who has
been dealing and lecturing students
about this matter we'll discuss
everything there is to know about this
key ingredient of massive success
self-discipline
it is often discussed about reasons of
humans existence who are we why are we
here
what are we meant to do but not many of
us try to see through the brick wall to
answer these questions and solve The
Riddles the road to success and
sustained happiness is only through
self-discipline it is a key ingredient
in the kitchen of Our Lives that makes a
dish full of success it is the pushing
power that brings our dreams to life the
goal of becoming successful is present
in everyone's agenda even though it is
quite difficult to achieve the results
we want however we should not neglect
the process because that's also very
important that includes a lot of hard
work challenges and focus patience
courage and not to give up in order to
do them we need stability and structure
in our lives therefore there's this main
factor affecting one's success which is
self-discipline hence it must receive a
lot of attention another utmost
important point is consistency it is a
commitment we do for a long period of
time in order to accomplish what we want
to nothing is effective if we do it for
one or two days but if we are persistent
good at time management have a clear
understanding of our Target and have the
confidence that we can do it then
success comes along
people change that's that's a fact
their convictions change according to
what stage of Life they are in for
instance we all know that our desires
changed a lot in comparisons to what we
desired when we were children teenagers
and they will continue changing and
that's why discipline is not only about
rules and regulations it is also about
applying them in the proper in the
proper way and the proper time uh these
factors play an essential role in
everyone's life
not getting discouraged by setbacks is
another key to remember
in life we may fail many times things
might not work out like we want to or
might not work out at all sometimes
that's why we must develop a mindset
that helps us understand that it is okay
to fail to get up and try again as
Abraham Lincoln once said
self-discipline is about choosing what
you want now and what you want most it
is about controlling your desires and
impulses while staying focused on what
needs to be done to achieve your goals
moreover people tend to confuse
motivation discipline in other words
they often trust motivation way more
than they should
it is only the first step in the process
motivation is similar to the period of
time when everything looks beautiful we
like a lot of things we like a
profession we practice many hobbies
everything inspires us and then
discipline is similar to adulthood most
humans once had extraordinary goals in
life as children most of them were asked
at least once or twice what do you want
to be when you grow up each of them gave
unique answers that fueled their
imaginations to the point that they were
determined on what they wanted however
not everyone will be able to fulfill
their childhood dreams only those who
suffer the pain of self-discipline and
hardship can enjoy the feeling of
success they say that self-discipline is
hard and not for weak people even though
they deep down want a life that comes in
a long term they succumb the short-term
pleasures
self-discipline from a student's
perspective can be quite challenging in
all senses we can say that uh it's a
wisdom it's some sort of wisdom only
those that only those with endurance can
possess it takes time and effort to
yield self-discipline within no matter
how we obtain it the easier hard way
students might be quick to lose it
students prefer easier and shorter
routes
that lead them to success they simply do
not want to put too much effort and time
into something that they're not sure
will benefit them
or or
simply put they believe that they are in
their blooming gears and want to enjoy
all the things at the same time more
than 80 percent of the students are not
willing to do what it takes to
accomplish their goals according to a
study carried out by a social Institute
for instance many students would rather
go partying and hang out with friends
rather than study for an important exam
since self-discipline is equality of
those who possess self-control in a
variety of situations most students fail
in being self-disciplined
uh humans in general especially students
who have less life experience tend to
make bad choices every day living the
after effects of what they choose leads
them to the blaming game they blame
everyone but themselves fault in
responsibility to not go together your
heart your life your happiness your
career and your success are all your
responsibilities
the idea of living life to the fullest
and blaming others have created an iron
wall between them and the
self-discipline they're trying to uh
build indeed self-discipline is for
those who resist the temptation of
current Pleasures most people visualize
self-discipline as something harsh that
is because they fail to exercise our
self-discipline muscle once they go to
the gym for self-discipline they have a
lot of challenges it is not easy to keep
yourself focused on one main thing only
uh but surely it is not impossible
and most of the time the end results are
success and happiness that came as a
chain reaction from the Bittersweet Road
or what people fail to realize is that
self-discipline is not locking yourself
up in a cage it is more like uh it is
more about self-control and time
management really it is about choosing
the right option that will profit you in
the future it is about having one goal
that will turn into habit and habit into
a willpower and so on and also the
willpower turned into a self-discipline
during adulthood we see all the
responsibilities we see all the
challenges that life has to give however
we decide to keep going
considering the problem during the
process we keep going this is a point of
discipline it is not because it's easy
but because even though we know it's
hard we decide not to give up
all things considered when all these
actions are under the control of nobody
but you when you do something not
because someone tells you but because
you want to that is kind of the the
simplest definition of self-discipline
and after you achieve that that is also
can be easily called success once humans
obtain self-discipline they can push
past their limits they put the uh they
put the highest faith in themselves they
can control what they think which leads
them to control what they do and
controlling what one can do leads to the
guaranteed success they persuaded for a
long time
and that looks like the end of our
today's episode thank you for listening
to language shapes perception with your
host Professor S I hope you enjoyed our
Deep dive into this modest elaboration
if you're Keen to see these ideas be
applied in your beautiful lives join our
next week when we'll be recording our
next episode tackling our next topic as
always you can head over to our YouTube
channel to sign up to our email list as
well as check out all the links and
resources in the show notes
[Music]
that's all for this episode folks see
you next time
[Music]